an elderly woman watches from her living
room window as heavy Sheets of Rain Fall
outside she rocks back and forth in her
chair nervously it's been raining for
days the road is washed out I can't get
into town what am I to do what am I to
do she says out loud to herself the
rocking chair creaks under her weight
but not as much as it had three days ago
before she ran out of food
I am so hungry the old lady mounts she
glances at the door that leads to her
basement maybe I can find something to
eat down there she stands up her 90 year
old bones Creak as she slowly shuffles
towards the basement door the empty
chair rocks back and forth from the old
woman's momentum as if someone is still
sitting in it she opens the door and
looks into the pitch black darkness
there are no windows down there the only
light is connected to a drawstring in
the middle of the room the old woman
slowly makes her way down the uneven
wooden steps when she reaches the bottom
she reaches out her wrinkled hand
groping in the darkness for the
drawstring her hand brushes something it
feels like sticky yarn then she feels
the legs of a spider Scurry up her arm
the old woman lets out a shriek as her
hand locates the string and she pulls
hard the light flickers on it creates a
dim glow but at least she can now see
what's in the basement the string swings
back and forth casting a snake-like
shadow on the far wall the old woman
scans the floor for anything to eat a
leftover tuna can some pickled
vegetables a wrap anything we'll do at
this point there is nothing there the
old woman feels her strength has been
almost completely drained she doesn't
know how she'll make it back up the
stairs in desperation she looks around
the basement One Last Time her eyes fall
on an old rusty saw she pauses for a
moment I need to eat she Whispers The
Old Woman slowly walks towards the saw
she picks it up and examines it God gave
me two hands for a reason she says her
eyes locked on the rusty blade she
places one hand on the wooden workbench
that sits against the wall and grips the
saw tightly with the other the old woman
takes a deep breath and brings the saw
down towards her hand where are we going
d-94322 asked the SCP agent driving car
house on Hadley Hill the agent responds
wow that doesn't sound creepy at all
d-94322 says as he cranes his neck to
get a glimpse of the top of the mountain
through the SUV window why don't we just
play the quiet game until we get there
the agent says as he focuses on the
pothole-ridden back roads of Mount Zion
Georgia
d-94322 holds on tightly to the handhold
above him to keep his body from slamming
into the door every time they go over a
big bump they continue on for a few more
minutes when a rundown house comes into
view the agent pulls off the road and
stops the SUV here you go he says
handing d-94322 in earpiece what am I
supposed to do with this d-94322 asks
just stick it in your ear the agent says
with just little contempt in his voice
you don't have to be rude about it
d-94322 replies as he grabs the earbud
and sticks it in his ear hello testing
anybody out there hello d-94322 can you
hear hear me says a voice in his head ah
yeah you can just call me d-94 for sure
d94322 is kind of a mouthful very well
the voice from the earbud agrees my name
is Dr Andrews I will be walking you
through this test with
scp-4173 all right doc shall we get this
party started d-94 says as he steps out
of the SUV he looks up at the house that
sits atop Hadley Hill the sky is dark
and clouds race over the mountain as if
they would rather be anywhere else but
here here we go d94 starts walking up
the slippery Hill being careful not to
fall he reaches the overgrown walkway
leading up to the house and pauses is
there a problem Dr Andrews asks now just
trying to psych myself up to go into
this creepy House response d94 what's
inside anyways that is not your concern
at the moment but if you do exactly as I
tell you you should be in and out and
note
whatever you say Doc d94 walks down the
path reaches his hand out and grips the
cool brass knob he turns it and pushes
the door open the inside of the house
smells like mothballs and decay all
right I'm in he says good head down the
hallway and turned to your left you'll
see a door that leads to the basement
let me know when you're there d94 walks
down the hallway the old wooden floor
groans under his feet he reaches the
basement door it's slightly ajar this
place gives me the creeps rightfully so
Dr Andrews chimes in it is an old spooky
house on top of an old spooky Hill in
the middle of nowhere obviously it's
going to be creepy an old woman died
here under mysterious circumstances
around 20 years ago but you don't really
need to worry about that no ghosts here
I think you think d-94 shots as he takes
a step away from the basement door
I'm just kidding there's nothing but
harmless old
scp-4173 in that house and when has an
SCP ever heard anyone right there is a
long uncomfortable pause
anyways why don't you head on downstairs
so we can get you out of there as soon
as possible yeah sure d-94 says as he
begins his descent into the darkness I
can't see anything is there a light no I
think it burnt out years ago but that's
okay I can guide you it's what I'm here
for says Dr Andrews walk towards these
walls but watch your head the ceiling is
low in that corner you'll see what
you're looking for when you get there
d94 is silent for a moment East he asks
turn left Dr Andrew's response oh all
right why'd you say so doc d94 turns
left and walks forward after a few feet
there's a loud bang as he slams his head
into the ceiling son of a [ __ ] I told
you to watch your head yeah thanks it
says d94 as he rubs the bump forming
beneath his hair this place is even
spookier than the first floor you know
that right I promise there's nothing in
that room right now that can hurt you Dr
Andrews reassures d-94 wait what do you
mean right now don't worry about it just
let me know when you reach the wall d-94
after a few seconds d94's eyes adjust to
the darkness he can just make out the
damp concrete wall in front of him it
looks as if the wall is perspiring I'm
here he says good there's a little door
maybe five feet to your left you see it
asks Dr Andrews d94 turns yeah I see it
it's closed the door itself is not very
big maybe a foot long and a half a foot
wide open it says Dr Andrew d-94
hesitates what what's in there nothing
just open it Dr Andrew repeats himself
no way man you're lying and I'm not
opening anything until you tell me
what's on the other side of that door Dr
Andrew's size we both know that you're
going to do as I say d-94322 you have no
other choice unless you want to go back
to that death row cell block where we
found you d94 shakes his head and rubs
the bridge of his nose fine
fine he says Dr Andrews can hear the
squeaking of hinges through the
microphone on d94's earbud it's open now
what do you see anything
ah no there's some cobwebs and dirt but
other than that it's just dark d94
thinks for a moment why is this little
door here is this some like pet door or
something you have to be I don't know
pretty small to get in there agreed just
hang tight and let me know when you hear
something we won't keep you there for
long here's something like like what
asks d94 you'll know when you hear it
says Dr Andrews five minutes go by
without a sound then 10 15. the basement
is damp and Cold d94 theme CC's
creatures scurrying around the floor but
he doesn't say anything because
acknowledging them makes his situation
more real and a lot more scary after a
half hour of waiting in silence d94
screams what the heck was that what was
what Dr Andrews is startled out of a
Daydream by the shot ounce of d94 in his
ear something just moved past the door I
definitely saw it what in God's name was
that yoast d94 Dr Andrews tries to
remain calm but he can barely contain
his excitement the entity in the wall is
why you're down there what do you mean
you said there wasn't anything down here
I said there was nothing down there that
could hurt you if you follow my
instructions this will continue to be
true can you hear anything asks Dr
Andrews no I can't hear it but before
d94 can finish his sentence a voice
speaks from behind the wall he can't
understand what the voice is saying at
first but as his heart begins to slow
and the blood stops thumping in his ears
d-94 can make out her words oh thank
goodness I wasn't sure you'd be able to
find me what took you so long says the
voice of an old woman d-94 takes a step
back from the door there's someone on
the other side of that wall he hisses
into the microphone at Dr Andrews tell
it that the road is out and you had to
find an other way up says Dr Andrews in
d94's earpiece what why just do it if
you want to get out of there d94 Dr
Andrew says a little impatiently ah the
the road is out so I had to find another
way up it says d-94 to the little open
door on the wall oh yes the rain washed
it out I was worried I wouldn't ever get
to see another person again being stuck
up here and all
can you see me asks the voice
um no I I can't says d94 doc what is on
the other side of that wall come over
here a little closer I I can't see you
properly either says the voice it's fine
you can get closer just don't touch the
door Dr Andrews says I really don't want
to do that says d94 do it and you will
be that much closer to getting out I
hate you whispersd94 he slowly
approaches The Little Door and speaks
into it hello oh there you are the voice
pauses as if whoever's speaking is
examining d94 I'm sorry I can't see like
I used to it's so dark in here and it's
been so long reach through the door and
let me feel your hands where I can tell
you're really there
what d94 steps away from the door no way
am I putting my hand in there come on
now don't be rude I just want to feel
that you're there it's been so long just
just a touch the voice says a little
harsher than before
screw you lady I'm not getting my hands
anywhere near This creepy hole in the
wall it says d-94 he turns around and
starts walking away from The Little Door
towards the staircase leading back to
the main level of the house before he
can put his foot on the first step d-94
hears Dr Andrew's voice screaming in his
ear stop moving look you're going to
have to do it we haven't been able to
recover anyone who refuses to do what
she asks I cannot guarantee your safety
unless you put your hand through that
door are you kidding me shouts d94
you're telling me that sweet creepy old
lady will somehow kill me if I don't do
what she asks we're not entirely sure
what happens but you need to put your
hand through that door if you want to
get out of there says Dr Andrews d-94
turns back toward the little door and
slowly approaches it this is my
nightmare he says more to himself than
anyone else he reaches out slowly and
puts his fingers through the doorway he
immediately pulls them back and steps
away from the door ah I I really don't
want to do this d94 Whispers he steps
forward again and sticks his hand all
the way through the doorway for a moment
nothing happens ah all right I've got my
hand in there now what oh I can chew now
you're right there thank you for coming
oh it's been so long since someone came
and with a gift as well oh sweet ling
you're so kind so kind to me gift
what gift d94 asks nervously it's so
dark and Lonesome and I've just been so
hungry for such a long time thank you
sweetling I'll take your gift from you
you are such a rude little brat you
don't really deserve it you've had it
for too long and you don't deserve it
it's mine now mine for my belly thank
you what are you talking about you
psycho d94 stutters suddenly something
grabs his hand and pulls him against the
wall he screams in agony as Dr Andrews
hears a wet ripping sound coming through
the microphone it sounds as if some type
of metal instrument is cutting through
flesh oh God no help me help me d94
screams please please please Dr Andrews
hears the sound of d94's body hitting
the floor as he passes out it's quiet
for a moment don't worry you ungrateful
child don't worry I'll fill you up too
you can have mine I'll give it to you
sweet boy good boy fill you up says the
old woman's voice from the other side of
the wall Dr Andrews listens as the
hinges of The Little Door squeak and it
clicks shut he picks up the phone next
to him and does it go in and get him
bring him back to site 94 for
observation and try to keep this one
alive please he hangs up the phone and
prepares the lab for d-94322 to be
brought in d94 slowly comes out of his
medically induced coma two days after
the incident with
scp-4173 he's stable but doesn't feel
great and he can't help but sense that
something is different d94 looks at
where his hands should be there's
nothing there that crazy old lady ate my
hand he starts screaming a medical team
rushes in as red lights begin to flash
and Sirens Blair they attempt to
restrain d94 during the struggle d94
catches a glimpse of himself in a mirror
on the far side of the room he stops
fighting for a moment there is a growth
expanding from his hand what the heck is
that he yells pointing to his reflection
d94 begins to struggle again this time
much more intensely he begins scratching
at the growth on the side of his head
felt much success in the process he
pushes the growth further into his skull
it penetrates his brain d94 blacks out
the medical team ties d94 to the bed and
tries to get a reading on his vitals the
growth is putting too much pressure on
his brain they Rush him to the ER but
d-94322 dies before he reaches the
operating table Dr Andrew stands over
the body of the deceased class D subject
cut him open he says to the doctor
standing in the room one of them pulls
out a scalpel and makes an incision into
the side of d94's head what is that one
of the doctors says the other bends over
to get a better look after a moment he
turns away and vomits into his face mask
Dr Andrews picks up a pair of forceps
off the table he sticks them deep into
the hole in the side of d94's head and
clamps down hard Dr Andrews out a
decomposing hand the fingers are still
moving as if trying to grab onto
something there is no explanation for
how it got in there but it is obvious
that
scp-4173 played some sort of role in the
phenomenon Dr Andrews goes back into his
office to review previous Case Files on
scp-4173 everyone who had put their hand
into the small doorway has been pulled
towards the wall and had their hand
chopped off the severed appendage never
ends up being a clean cut which leads Dr
Andrews to hypothesize the gruesome
makeshift operation is done with some
sort of tool with teeth once the hand of
the victim is severed
scp-4173 always thanks the person for
their gift she then informs them not to
worry about their hand as it will be
replaced but then something incredibly
strange happens like with d94 a decaying
hand will appear somewhere in the body
but it isn't always inside the head in
fact depending on how polite the test
subject is to the old one and behind the
door the closer to the wrist the
decaying hand actually ends up for the
test subjects who are rude to the old
lady the decaying hand ends up in some
pretty interesting places she really
hated d-94322 Chuckles doctor Andrews to
himself Dr Andrews continues flipping to
the back of the file on
scp-4173 the SCP Foundation doesn't
quite know how it happens but people who
refuse to offer their hand to scp-4173
suffer a worse fate than those who
surrender to the old lady in every case
where a subject tries to get away from
the small door some inexplicable Force
seems to grab them from behind and drag
them through the tiny opening in these
cases there is nothing left of the test
subject it is likely fatal as a human is
much smaller than the opening itself so
the only way a body could fit through
the doorway is if every bone is broken
and every muscle compressed to a quarter
of its actual size I'm not sure which is
worse Dr Andrews says aloud as he closes
the file on
scp-4173 he glances at the picture paper
clip to the front of the manila folder
depicting the tiny doorway he can't
quite pinpoint why but the fact that the
door slowly closes after the old woman
gets what she needs from her victims
sends chills down his spine the words of
the old woman echo in his head don't
worry I'll fill you up too you can have
mine I'll give it to you
sweet boy good boy fill you up now go
check out
scp-2696 haunted Victorian mansion and
scp-1461 house of the Worm for more
frightening anomalous locations